sorry welcome to this game this is a
rapid game 15-minute chess ya kun ama
hakuna MA yeah this is a video that is
some very fresh I mean I will upload
this right after recording the reason is
that for this day I originally thought
that you'd in addition to my three
minutes videos that would be a video on
the World Championship match game 12 but
obviously there is no game 12s cards and
has won the match already so as I want
this additional content in i started
this rapid game to complete my daily
upload of three Blitz videos plus an
additional video ok we have a rare line
of the Kings Indian I'm going to go with
this h4 h5 idea that I think is quite
often interesting trying to play a sort
of preemptive strike on the Kings side
quite often black reacts with the myth
h5 yes and this son is some really
limiting his options on the kingside
somewhat i wonder i am always a tricky
question should you play f3 because
night in 2g form is an issue or or not
maybe i can really just take this night
if it if it comes I mean something like
Nigeria x pawn takes then aged 5 should
be should be good for wide and if he
takes with the bishop I can still play
f3 night GE to which is maybe not that
bad or f3 and then night age 3 f2 can
also be
considered yeah here this is better if
he gets to see 5 money for point Hank so
I probably have to play a three at some
stage but maybe Bishop d1 okay then I
chief I am okay so i have three years
good good after all um yeah do I play
Bishop do you one now Bishop give 192
Bishop c2 yeah it is slow but I have to
somehow organize my pieces night h 2 F 2
nite h3 f 2 would have been interesting
actually intending maybe g4 later hmm ok
now this gets more interesting now from
for him and some my bishop is not only
to anymore okay what if i take with the
night in this position is this somehow
the idea is that Knight takes Knight
takes pawn takes f night she frequently
but he will play a five years okay Jim I
don't like that position so much
probably probably right to e28 bishop d1
wasn't a good plan this is really
directed against f5 but he plays on them
on the queenside now and if he gets in
b5 he definitely has a good position so
i will try to hinder that not he is
Queen B 6 though which is possible Queen
B 6 before in
yeah yeah black is totally fine him now
if ok I think will be six is the right
move if he's not doing that I might be
able to play Knight b5 and 92 c 3 which
at least them somehow harmonizes my
nights I didn't play this good well I
mean ng has multiple ways to play this
is just one of them but this is I think
a very sensible approach yeah how do i
play that Queen B form much might be
played really quickly
all night be three sometimes the Queen
before this even a force is hanging yeah
I probably have to have to Castle
connecting rooks maybe to powering
Bishop c2 on the immediate Bishop see to
it could really take on between so it's
really really on this plate that really
the scissor and it happened to me
earlier and a blitz game where it try to
the same variation it is somewhat
similar to the potato to the Auerbach
and it shouldn't be that bad but I am
NOT playing it right
I 11 really serious issue is that i
don't really have a plan in this
position that's really very often a
problem in chance if you don't have a
plan then then you're in trouble and I
mean it like I mean not having a plan in
terms of I don't think there is anything
great not just that I don't see anything
but i think really there is nothing much
that i can do we can try to double on
the C file for example him I came at
least with rook FC eight it's pretty
clear that is not planning and five in
the near future not that that this is
necessarily any good but it really seems
like he does not want to play it um yeah
can i play 9 p-5 here and now it is
bearish this is a very shaky here c2 and
stuff
maybe rook see one Roxy one he cannot
take on a4ai think so look see one maybe
I can play Knight be five now oh let's
say on the next move might be five
Bishop takes Queen takes p for 84 85
something like that okay goes for those
for this bishop yes certainly certainly
possible but at least them I don't think
this is so so tragic so tragic for me
okay three queen before it's nowhere
maybe look a three queen before Queen d1
and tending rook be three maybe maybe
this is a way to activate a little bit
Nazi for a Quincy for that's 9 p-5 it
should be good for me Queen the Queen on
before it doesn't have many squares
really can i somehow try to to trap it
and even if I get in something like 93
the still Quincy form now I think this
is the seventies an idea intending would
be three our group III might play Bishop
a for now that I think of it ma'am I had
to play more
yeah I think on rupee three you really
can take on a form that solves the whole
issue for him and makes Queen d1
probably rather useless i mean i can't
play something like rugby three Bishop
f4 before Bishop deewani rook takes b7
now that's actually not that bad my rook
is on the seventh and the light squared
Bishop bully traded now that that's
actually quite good for wild I think
yeah so maybe route b3 is an idea I will
be frequency form might be five Queen a
phone yeah I'm just trying to think
about what is in the position for me
it's not totally clear what his move is
so just considering what I would do if
it is my move he has a wide range of
possible moves maybe
a good positional idea for example would
be king age 7 and tending bishop age 6
maybe really rupee 3 as possible that
this really is annoying fan group III
quincy frog b7 i can just take the pawn
and then i'm even threatening be three
winning the Queen funny not such an easy
position so he basically he ignores it
in some way so I do this right okay and
then he can take on a for ICS he wants
to he wants to protect b7 him I see yeah
that makes quite some sense um group III
bishop and follow before should give one
rupee six we should be too well that
that's not enough it's not enough okay
so rugby 3 is not really great
something I queen bee three is to
totally pointless okay I'm so rugby 32
should be 49 a fork we need for that
does not lead anywhere
this yeah but if I don't play rugby 3
what what what sense does all this make
probably not much Oh p3 Bishop f4 not a
form Queenie 493
Oh what what kind of moves do I have
besides can i prepare would be three
somehow with Luke who gave one that sets
really crazy
I can put it on b5 at the end of this
line rugby three Bishop f4 look takes
before Bishop d1 rook b5 should be to
only move 92 takes on c1 shop c1 and I'm
attacking 85 and b7 and I have 93 this
is not such a bad end game let's do this
I hope I'm not miscalculating here maybe
place Quincy for you but I don't really
believe that Quincy faultless route b6
and b3 is a queen trap which is really
problematic I think yeah he has to play
Bishop f4 is really the only move Bishop
f4 look before Bishop the one rupee five
it's bishop with a check that has no
square so has to take only two
ninety-two and then I have this this
pressure rising rukon be five which will
win one of the points and b7 on I know I
wanted to do this right we should be one
and Ruby 5s and he has to take on e 2
now I think there's no other square so
then I take with the night and I hope
that at the end i will get 1 point back
with my active rook I'm basically
threatening look-see at Roxy 893 and I
will get one of the pawns back and after
that I will maybe actually have the more
active position I have to do this so
that i can play Knight c3 if he goes
rook c8 and need to have 93 to block the
C file should be able to enter with the
rook
now if you can do something like b6 yes
v6s we should be 397 f-93 night if form
yeah maybe maybe this is what he needs
to try to defend yes definitely so the
group here is this is active but also
cannot cannot do much more 97 93 and 94
so is going on full fledge defensive
mode okay so um i have to i think i have
to regroup here or not night a for
Bishop da the 3d let's let's do that
tending night b5 rooks III here I just I
just blundered H form oh no that was not
good yeah I am and he can play 95
because if I capture my that's not good
there are now two points is too much I
think if it was only the Queen side I
mean if I still have the NH point NH
porn this is this would be still an
interesting interesting idea maybe not
not correct but it at least them what
would be interesting in some way but
here I'm just material down
that was a really bad game I have giving
away aged fries really bad I mean it
wasn't it wasn't so great anyway I
didn't really didn't really appreciate
this is totally passive defense but it
it was the best defensive player he
sometimes happens because you are you're
so focused on playing actively in the
end game that you sometimes don't really
think about the passive defense that
much and it is sometimes the case that
you have really have to play this
passive defense Jeff I don't want to
take but it's hard not to hear
night c4 may be threatening to take on
c5 then of course I didn't really think
about that so much
no a terrible game oh yes it's c4 I'm
well I probably not resigning but I can
you didn't do that for some reason yeah
okay it is it is also this is also
winning of course for black just
standing here just has to play some
correct breakthrough maybe bishop I
don't know Bishop f6 and 84 or something
but some I really have nothing great i
can do here let's try to try to stay on
the board this might also be right might
be five chick you can go to d if you can
take d5 there are any chick
check that's anyway here forward maybe
maybe this King see 496 which is very
cheap very cheap trick but rookie one is
at least a little threat here okay still
can go to e6 okay but check maybe here
it could have gone to sea for actually
now i'm at least activating my king a
little bit and my upon wow it is so
clear this is so clear
so 97 now attending a seven yeah I'm
very close to promoting check here no
9797 I can go shop d8 somehow a seven
bishops e7 takes takes mmm yeah those
pawns they are still very dangerous and
they are still very dangerous I'm a
seven look a seven i am rook e8 there is
nothing there m 97 there some other way
after should be aid I can take it a
salad it's not really convincing hmm
yeah I don't know it's it it is still
not so great really I mean he really
didn't play this bit as well giving my
apron all this leeway but I still don't
see how to win maybe this one a seven he
has to go back to it and now now maybe
try to to get to the pawns here first
maybe this is a try to win the game like
King b3 and trying to grab it ok I'm
trying that it'sit's may be risky it's
may be risky to do I can play Bishop the
eighth maybe push up to d8 Bishop to b6
hmm probably sm
I let us make some sense okay it's just
I okay if I take he wants to go see for
I guess
that's true
okay so let's get to the beep on then e
to King rookie one picks up the pawn and
otherwise i take p 3 here
slowking real Bishop Dean ok so
and now I don't know here really what do
we had game e 2 I wanted to go rook 27
not sure if this is any good sign this
check look at the 750 893 check King III
I can I cannot take it unfortunately ok
Knight c3 is yes c4 check as well time
morning here see for chick and things
like that oh wow oh and what a terrible
game really first I screw it up then he
screws it up and then i screw it up
again no okay white resigns Wow yeah
well this is I mean I cannot believe
that this is any good still for blanket
the apron or is it still winning I
really thought that I should have
something here with the port on a 71
computer still gives like a total win
yeah maybe I mean yeah I'm totally dead
lost and that was original price that I
somehow got some activity at least but
it seems there is nothing so I didn't so
we with this all the screw-ups that i
mentioned day they didn't happen he was
still winning all the time I wasn't sure
yeah most really miss played this
completely
so yeah the comp wants to do this and
gives me an action or ll kill about
equal yeah i can i get the pawn back now
I really underestimated that he is just
doing this this passive defense but
passive is good here and I made a
mistake out of course I shouldn't have
not I just gave away the age for porn I
really blundered this I just have to do
this and continue from here I mean he
I'm upon down but it's not so easy for
him and I can try to put the night on b5
and try to invade on the C file it
probably won't happen but this is
something that I can still fight well I
Justin I just forgot about the pawn and
yeah yeah I'm just I'm just lost
basically I mean I allowed be five which
was another mistake but here I'm really
just two points down for for nothing the
structure is very compact I don't have
have anything active here as
compensation for for my pawns um yeah I
think here is really really about equal
not sure this idea was interesting I
still like it actually a compounds to do
King f2g three and then rugby three I
don't know it does not seem very human
to me yeah this is this is ok I have to
I have to attract take with the with the
night I was it wasn't so I really didn't
think about this passive defense that
really was my problem I thought I get
the palm like somehow wonder well here I
was a little bit afraid of that but I'm
justifying am getting getting a really
good position he
based on the fact that his bishop will
is bad and will stay bad yeah this is
just a pawn down in a way especially
after I blunder H Freud's two pawns now
okay not a good game I hope you still
enjoyed it thanks for watching